arresting you on suspicion of the murder
of your late wife
joking
this dash cam footage from a police car
shows ian stewart's indignant reaction
when officers arrested him for the 2010
murder of his wife diane at the home
they shared in cambridgeshire
the jury was told on the opening day of
this trial that 61 year old stewart was
already a convicted murderer he'd killed
his fiancee the children's author helen
bailey in 2016 in hertfordshire and
hidden her body in a cesspit while she
was planning their wedding he was
planning her murder he stood to gain 1.8
million pounds plus two properties
it was that conviction that prompted
detectives to look at the sudden death
six years earlier of 47 year old diane
her death had initially been put down to
an epileptic fit
this was the 999 call stewart made after
he'd murdered her the judge described it
as a charade is she awake no no she's
not awake is she breathing
is she breathing no i don't think so in
a statement diane's sister wendy and
brother christopher said diane was a
very special caring and capable person
she will always be greatly loved and
hugely missed by her family and all who
knew her
she's not awake you didn't think that
she was breathing how did you check if
you were breathing
during police interviews stewart said
nothing
i believe that he felt he was
more intelligent and more superior to
the officers that were investigating him
i think he really looked down on the
investigation and what we were trying to
achieve
he received 96 000 pounds in insurance
payouts and cash after diane's death the
judge described him as a callous man who
had carried out strikingly similar
murders
the whole life order means ian stewart
will die behind bars
ender brady sky news in cambridgeshire